vous n'êtes plus anonyme est ce que vous
ne regrettez pas l'animal je ne sais pas
répondre à votre question je ne sais pas
pour vous dire au début de cloques quand
j'ai commencé à faire ce métier je dois
dire que je regretter d'être la vie
parce que l'anonymat ça voulait dire ça
voulait dire la méconnaissance et là ma
connaissance ça voulait dire le drame
quotidien l'une du jour le jour en face
d'abominables est maintenant vide mange
sur une ça mais je dois dire que je
m'arrange pour ne pas être
trop mêlé aux eaux jean king kino qui
voit bien que je ne suis pas la lettre
anonyme mais qui nous font bien sentir
le plus souvent je te dire une façon
gentil d'une façon gentille parce que je
suis un romantique et les artistes
romantiques en les ennuie pas trop dans
le rang les insultes ça n'est pas comme
les comics les comics sont les gens qui
font rire sur la scène temps disons plus
sur la scène peut-être qu'il ne rit pas
comment les autres vous adresse la
parole dans la rue au hasard
comment sont-ils avec eux se passent
très différent ce but mais une chose qui
m'a frappé pour lui j'étais il n'ya pas
longtemps la télévision française pour
la qualité et les actualités la première
chaîne voilà vous m'avez filmer le long
du quai aux fleurs parce que j'ai une
chanson laquelle je parlais du quai aux
fleurs et attendant en retrouvant les
équipes techniques ont été transportés
de don d'un endroit à l'autre
j'ai vu un type qui avait les apparences
et pillé qui étaient présents le mans un
ouvrier a mesuré aux verts qui gagnent
qui gagne pas sa vie comme il le
faudrait il m'a dit
il a remué suivre
lorsque vous chantez est ce que vous
avez envie d'avoir des gens comme ça
dans la salle oui mais je ne sais pas je
suis toujours aveuglés par les brèches
guitare comment sentez vous cette salle
qu'elle dont vous chante
les respirations les mouches qui va être
un peu plus parce qu'ils m'écoutent
conviendrait de les connaître que
disponibles
à certaines heures parle de la nuit et
d'une machine à sous avec des problèmes
d'hommes simplement des problèmes de
mélancolie à en boire et ont surtout le
dragage du comptoir et on se dit qu'il
est bien tard il est bien tard qu'il est
bien tard qu'il est prête à richard
encore un petit pour la route
richard à part un petit vite fait mais
je richard le dernier
lorsque les gens sortent du spectacle
j'ai pensé vous qu'ils disent je ne sais
pas si je veux je chante dans l'embarras
en deux heures sans entracte
parce que l'entracte c'est une coupure
d'abord pour les gens à qui ça permet de
parler pile souvent de boire et à moi ça
me permet de d'attendre poudre commencé
alors c'est pas la peine sympathique
doublement je fais pas d'entracte jambe
pendant deux heures je vois là et c'est
beaucoup mieux alors le suspense les
gens je ne le sais pas et puis des fois
je voudrais savoir et puis j'ai vite que
ça va nous être heureux lorsque vous
avez terminé un spectacle mais vous
savez à un niveau moyen
je crois que il faut pas prendre mal ce
que je vais vous dire c'est comme quand
le chauffeur d'autobus pour un maïs
heureux de laisser son son camion ont
terminé cette fin ces autobus au
terminus des pyrénées c'est un peu ça
c'est un métier où il faut être lucide
et ne pas avoir l'air l'air d'être une
cité seybouse a bondi connais des
comédiens qu'on aidait les cabots et
bien sûr toutes sortes des cabots et des
comédiens c'est pas facile et c'est mon
métier comme ses amitiés au musée de
données découdra monde si lebron sommet
non les gens ne font pas le rapport
faisant métier ou faisant nous
travaillons
je m'excuse de le dire 5 quand j'écris
de la musique travaille pas mais quand
je suis en scène je travaille parce que
je suis devant un incroyable où je fais
tomber les pièces comme je peux ramasser
puis pendant deux heures comme ça
[Musique]